so this comes from the UK Brendan
Kavanaugh the guy likes playing the
piano he's got a YouTube channel it's
really popular and so he was playing in
a mall at a public piano which anyone
can have access to and this is what end
up
[Music]
happening Chinese ja ever go oh yeah of
course of course we got the Chinese
here because for Chinese oh yeah did you
as all us your
cameras I don't know
we we're not allowed yeah yeah we not
allowed you're not allow because we for
Chinese T this is not disco it's not
disco
yeah okay so these people I guess are
celebrating some from China maybe the
new year and they're like you can't film
us but they're not filming them I'm just
telling you what they're saying and I'm
just telling you what I what I saw fair
I'm going to hit
play sorry you're right right I'm wrong
let's carry on let's work together okay
I don't want no problem sir I'm a good
man sorry I'm just telling you what I
saw
okay why you just look so threaten all
of a sudden I'm scared why I don't know
but I am so please let's carry
on no Disco This is not disclosable it's
not disclosable I really it yeah
yeah get
trouble it's like g game g g g
g I already know what you going to do
excuse me you can't
feel what are you
doing excuse me are you filming right
now are you you can't fil me you can't
film me excuse me are you filming me are
you filming me you can't stop filming me
you're putting you're putting the camera
in my face I don't appreciate it
taiwan's not a country
don't
Yan put you in prison mate so so just
like that according to the [__] Chinese
what we not allowed to film you is that
right so basically um we will much
appreciated and you are whatever you're
doing that don't put her face on on on
TV then get your face out of there you
put yourself next to the men being like
I don't want you to fil my face no
matter what you do make sure you don't
hey don't fil my don't fil my face
please please stop filming me don't
Don't film my face you can't do that y
if you don't get the [__] out of here
all right you can't invade my space like
that I'm not
Taiwan so what what will happen if just
don't do it please I I really appreciate
that we we just very sensitive about
this is I'm really really sorry but we
love your music want to stay here for a
lot longer mean the the only thing is
it's just it's just like there's other
people filming as well and that's
absolutely fine that's the other
people's business they can make their
own decision absolutely so how come it's
the only it's just not us please just
not us no but what I'm saying is there's
other people filming you as well oh no
no no it it's just just make sure that
we are very very secure in the reason
that we don't want our voice or picture
being filmed and then yeah that's just
the relationship between you and me you
and us Bas what relationship just now we
are very so I'm going to repeat that all
of us we cannot share our images online
yeah there's no weakness or Choice
that's our right oh so it's not a legal
thing it is a legal thing because this
is our right what we're protecting and
we want don't want our boys or images to
be revealed on no it's not you can't be
in a public place and demand privacy
it's not the way it works now people
can't go and film you actively trying to
and then use it for commercial purposes
but if someone's filming something and
you're walking into the frame they don't
really need release forms cuz you're in
a public space that's the way it works
when you live in a free Society that's
how it works you m this [__] was
over there and now he came all the way
from over there to over here speaking in
the microphone just make sure that you
don't film and and we don't listen to
our voice
and we don't and then you no no sir no
sir welcome this is called freedoms and
rights you don't like them you go back
to China um suck a dick really
appreciate it this is not your fault
obviously and this is not our fault
obviously we we have our own agreement
with other people that we cannot be
shown online yeah so sorry about this so
who's allowed to record you just just
making sure you're not recording us yeah
because if you are recording us that one
we are saying this we're still recording
and then we will put a legal action into
it okay yeah we will put a legal action
into it we will I'm sorry this is the
end of the conversation this is our
right we protecting and that's it but
what right I don't understand image
Right image right yeah we're not sharing
this are you from China I that's not a
question we the only thing we are
arguing is that we are protecting our
own image right you're not sharing but
this were in public yeah exactly no no
sharing so we're not allow no sharing
yes no sharing us share yourself that's
fine don't share okay please share me
instigator I appreciate it share
me came out of no and I'm next to him
oops I
consent I'm really sorry we're on a
schedule
here sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry
I'm sorry I'm so sorry
he so I'm sorry I I kind of screamed
there I shouldn't have screamed I'm just
sorry it's just that it's you it's just
like it's just it just came to trigger
some [__] out it's just like when a
[__] Cuts me off and then stop
stom on the break and say if you were
such in such a hurry why don't you just
[__] go hey he I if if you were such
in a hurry like right now you're on a
schedule if you're so much on a schedule
a get the [__] out of here nobody calls
you over if you don't want to be seen
online maybe don't make a public
commotion in public stupid not the
brightest a free country m true in
communist China now you know I'm sorry
this is racist now we have no we're not
in communist China we're
country that's not he's right this is
what the rights are in that country in
China in communist China cuz this is a
communist country he didn't say anything
crazy these people are using the race
card whoa yeah whoa that's now you said
these people yeah whoa yeah yeah yeah
but I got the Uno reverse card behind my
race
card yeah right you're exactly so you
call me racist I'd be like well you know
what Chinese liquor store owners are
like and I throw that [__] on the table
wow yeah yeah you be in the hood with
your little corner store but I see the
way you scaring me and following me down
the aisle Uno reverse wow yeah try to
say something you don't play that no I
don't my deck is full of race cards and
Uno reverses you can't beat me God damn
yeah I lost one of my toes you lost one
of your toes just one that's enough
though some almost said something to me
I'm
disabled I use that card too you really
loseing one of your THS mm let me see
yeah look at my feet baby yeah look at
myet baby this is all theoy to get you
to stare at my feet for a few seconds I
don't give a you don't mind no you got
beautiful feet okay that's a
problem un
reverse good you got me never mind you
got me you got me the longer this
channel goes on the boundaries between
me and preach are eroding slowly and
slowly I worked with this guy for8 years
I have never looked at his toes in my
life we're in a free country mate we can
FM where we want can call the police if
you want I'll be quite happy to call the
police know but listen we're all free in
mate this is free but we don't want when
you're in Rome you do as the Romans do
sorry you're a Roman yeah it's it's a
saying Oh my days when you're in Rome
you like the Romans are you
Roman
are you wrong said that [__] with his
chest like that was an argument are you
wrong yo sorry sorry wait we don't want
do it yeah sorry you don't want to do
what to share our share our image you
you got to walk away then cuz it's a
public space yeah yeah yeah definitely
so I I tell you I just tell my my choice
yeah they don't want to so our okay we
walk away then so yeah yeah yeah then
but but we want to use this piano this
is a public one is a public people of
the world is
official
Karen has been around the world Karen is
no such thing as a white thing anymore
there are Karens in all shapes and forms
and this is a whole troop of them we can
use it as well yes you can yes anyone
can film because in the UK it's a free
country and anyone anyone
right not in public in China but we're
we're not in China no I help my Cho I
don't but we are in Britain Great not CH
I say I'm also Bri I'm also British okay
I'm also British I'm also British but I
don't want to use my you got a Chinese
flag it doesn't matter the Chinese flag
why you touching her stop touching her
don't touch her please do not touch her
please you are not the same age please
do not touch her
oh
n all the you a [__] he's like
this this [__] is he's fling
[__] he's Gambit at this point oh my God
I'm
listening flinging all the cars that is
crazy yo that's crazy uhuh get the [__]
out of here I just got satellite image
of this man reaching halfway across the
world godamn that reach was crazy I hope
he stretched they picking it up on all
the setups God damn we see it
yo that was crazy nah you nah
nah way he screw don't touch her he
touched the flag relax calm down relax
you could have just said hey don't touch
her that would have been fine you
screamed it and you make it it you
mention AG you know what you're doing
you're using this whole victim ideology
that you also know probably wouldn't
work in most of China and you're using
it here because you think it's an
effective tool to get it what you want
cuz you know you have no legal recourse
don't touch her please don't touch her
please don't touch her don't touch her
what's what's don't shot don't shoot
please don't touch her please don't
touch her please don't touch her we love
your art we love your music but we are
trying to have because you're touching
my friend are you allowing her to touch
you I touch the flag I touch the flag it
doesn't matter you're approaching her
with hand you're getting a bit
aggressive oh yeah don't film me but let
me film look at the bit in the back
don't fil me
but let me film this that don't want to
be filming standing right here filming
people oh if you don't get the [__] out
of here yeah right from the chest that's
what right from the chest she was so
quick [__] get the [__] out of here and
it's so crazy because generally when
Chinese people travel they're some of
the best behaved people but then you see
this [__] and it's like what
the I got to slow you down down there
buddy I know what you're doing do you I
know what you're doing you I love me
some Chinese tourists you trying to you
trying to there's nothing better than
when they bathe in our canals in her
water
fountain I think we better leave this
I'm sorry you can't touch her please
touch me please don't touch her please
don't touch her please don't reach your
hand please say sorry to her well I want
you to say please say sorry to her no
we're not interest that's fine we're not
talking about two race this is not a
racist issue please don't call us not in
China this is the moment that you're
trying to reach your hand touch her
without her per I don't want to touch
him at all that's good stay away don't
touch her you go we're in a country now
mate democrac do not touch her do not
touch her I'm not touching tou do not
touch her I don't know do not touch her
do not touch her do not touch her do not
touch her are you miming me are you
miming me you're miming me you're miming
me you're Ming me I am you what you
going to do that it
yay yay
yeah I am I'm also I'm also allowed to
Mock You yep what are you going to do
what are you going to do oh hello police
he's mocking me that what you going to
do oh actually they do call the police
they better oh call them you might be
surprised
watch wait for it what's her name what's
my name yeah what's your name what's her
name you trying to answer or not do you
want to answer if you don't want to
answer that's your right answer my right
are you going to tell me my right not
telling you anything I just want you to
not reach your hand to my friend I don't
want you to shout mate fine you don't
reach your I'm are you going to
apologize are you in the Communist party
or
something stop judging stop judging why
are you calling us communist
why like any country why are you
discriminating a different country why
are you discriminating a different
country why are you getting excited
because you're discriminating another
country how am I
discriminating now this you canot say
like this way who are you who are you
why you say like this way who are you
who are
you
basically I know but we're walking
around
ex the cop showed up he said uh they're
a public place they're in a public place
if they're filming you show up they're
allowed to film straight up he's like is
this why I'm here yeah he's already
pissed off he's already annoyed he's
already annoying cops get called for
dumb [__] on a regular basis they get
called for dumb [__] on a regular basis
people call the police for things that
not crying we should find you because
I'm here for that that's public
disturbance they probably start
shouting yes sir yeah come and talk to
me I'll talk to you I'll talk you car
I'll told you car at the piano yeah but
can you just come talk this is not to go
on your channel this is me talking to
you well listen K we're in a public
space just have a conversation with this
in my face please if you're recording me
list record listen this this is going on
your YouTube channel but I need to speak
to you without this being on your
YouTube channel well what about what is
he public in a public space listen can I
just have a conversation with you please
without your friend video no because
because the camera never life good
absolutely he said a camera never lies
and he said it straight to her face and
let me tell you guys and he's also
allowed to [__] film I think it's
good to be diplomatic with cops if you
try to film and they trying to get you
out of it no first off they got body cam
footage they filming you why can't you
film them for your own protection to
make sure the footage never gets edited
and you catch your
perspective I've seen them cut audio
from body cam footages I've seen them
turn them [__] off keep your cameras
on you're still a human after all you
know what I understand and I respect the
job that you do but you're still a human
and the number of times that I've been
[__] over and [__] like that and
people try cops try to lie and stuff
like that look the camera you going to
keep that camera on you best believe you
best believe you're human like anybody
you're not a super human you're a human
also you're a public servant the public
should have access to you doing your job
you may not like the scrutiny but at the
end of day our tax dollars pay your
bills and pay your salary so you should
be beholding to us so why shouldn't we
be able to inspect you when you're doing
your duties mm camera stays on good for
you Brandon
listen I got my camera
on just have a conversation this is
going on your YouTube channel and I
don't want you to go on your YouTube
well don't talk to me then Carri listen
listen she's krie we're in Britain we're
in a public space we' got three
countries first the matter
isun
comment I said you're waving a communist
flag that's what I said and the hands
were meant to be going to water you
trying to touch was not trying to touch
it that's why
okay so I have a camera they've
requested that the video where they've
approached gets deleted and not used on
your channel there's money being made
and they work our company then their
faces can't be sh well they shouldn't be
you're not their private security agent
I'm not their private security agent and
we're in a free country we're in a free
space we're not causing the trouble the
problem is not the US Car the problem is
they are coming over telling us what to
do and playing the piano now fair is
fair but you are not their private
security guards I never said and I'm
having a conversation with you and we're
in a free space in a free country I'm
not causing any
trouble does an allegation be made and
that's why what's the allegation now you
told me to stop filming and now you say
there's an allegation
yo let's
[Music]
go
[Laughter]
[Music]
I second that last statement the camera
never Li that's why I film youve told me
to turn off my camera and now you're
saying I've got what's the why the
reason why I'm asking you not to kill me
is because I know that you are pushing
this on your YouTube doesn't matter
where it goes we're in a free true sorry
we're in a democracy we're not in China
and that's not racist that's truth
that's what our forefathers exactly but
you can't say things like that I you
can't just say things like that that
we're in a free country no that we're
not in China we Chinese people well they
came listen krie if I was over in China
and I started laying the law down to
Chinese people at the piano telling them
that what they cannot cannot do do you
think that's appropriate they came over
here the guy started shouting at me and
he said you're not allowed to film
you're not allow and I said sorry we're
in Britain un allowed to play and I said
you're waving a communist flag and then
he said you're racist so if I've done
anything's wrong tell
me okay we're in a free this is a free
speech issue I'm sorry this is a free
speech issue we are I'm not causing any
trouble they are the ones making a fuss
and they shouldn't get the police as
their private security I think nobody
said that had they who said that and on
top of that krie you told me to stop
filming and then you said there's an
allegation now if I didn't have my
camera how would I prove my innocence
one thing that's very important it's
very hard to do whenever you need to do
those kind of situations especially with
the police the thing that's very hard to
do is keep calm it's really hard
especially when it keeps on happening to
you it's really hard to keep calm but I
got to applaud this dude for keeping Cal
and being like nah be that's not what it
is nah you're doing this and this and
that and such and sometime it really
feels like they playing you like idiots
but he really got it the fact that he's
staying calm kudos to him oh no
listen from China listen you can't say
that what they're from
China from China why can't you say
they're from China when they're
literally celebrating some Chinese New
Year thing and they're waving around a
bunch of Chinese flags how's that
pejorative not consider it from China
well when they're trying to apply
standards that don't apply in the in a
democratic country with free rights and
Free Speech
yeah I don't see nothing wrong I don't
think there anything wrong with a little
bumping
grin they they
they well can I just say they're from
China without the F
Sor listen they are waving a communist
flag and I said you're waving a
communist flag is that racist to say
they've got a communist
flag listen I'm just playing at the
piano they stood by the piano I was
filming and then they started laying
down the
law
it's not your job you should listen you
should tell I'm not telling them
anything that you're telling me to tell
them okay okay get on play your piano
I'll have a discussion with them right
tell them we're in a free country there
we go we're in a free is anyone watching
this you see we got the Communists here
telling me not to do I'm just going to
play some boogy Woogie it's Matty
England there mat we need you down at
the station live your life you famous
now yep yeah you guys did a you wanted
privacy well you're not going to get it
every reaction channel will be covered
this you famous now I'll say this too
okay after this this man started getting
a bunch of threats uh Chinese people all
over were starting to congregate putting
up pages to have his video taken down
they've been trying repeatedly to try to
get it down um I know that the piano
that was used here has been cording off
and no one's allowed to use it anymore
after this so you can imagine you can't
have no nice things we can't have any
nice things this guy was playing and
then you guys will add I in yo make a
whole big old fuss and thank God he put
that [__] on YouTube so people people
could put the truth you know what yeah
it is what it is he did he did what he
was supposed to do and China does not
play they they operate like gangsters if
they don't like someone organizing says
organization says the whole government
comes down if you recognize Taiwan as a
free country the government says you're
no longer allowed to stream anything
from there they'll block you IP they do
a lot of crazy stuff I've watched them
handle these things this way and they
export their authorit
authoritarianism yeah overseas they do
this with Hollywood movies all the time
because so many Hollywood movies are
filmed in China and so many them r on
international box office hits and huge
Market is China you're not allowed to
say certain things about that country in
any of your films you're not allowed to
if an actor in a movie says anything
about China the whole movie gets
scrapped in terms of being played over
there so we should never allow these
kinds of people to have a say in how we
operate with our Western democracy the
same way if they want sport movies that
say bad things about the West we would
bring it the other way around they would
never allow it they would never allow it
so I have no quals about people saying
bad things about China I don't support
the country I never plan on visiting I
don't think I can because I've been
pretty critical of China in the past so
I wouldn't even try I wouldn't suggest
it I wouldn't try not even
a a layover no no no I'm very careful
with not even a layover nope so that's
how I feel about all that so my thoughts
on this uh they're dead wrong and I'm
glad that the man was filming everything
and he kept on filming it cuz I've seen
people delete their footage and regret
it later on so many times you do not
stand to gain anything by deleting that
footage anything else you want to say no
all right think about it too cuz if they
come back and say this and that and he
didn't have no footage it said he said
they said y he said they said cuz they
got seven friends with them saying he
touched her he put his hands we all saw
what happened yeah this man was just
screaming for a performance don't touch
her don't touch her don't touch her
don't touch her she was she wasn't even
stressed pulling every card you're not
the same age as her y get the [__] out
of him so what if he was a 30-y old man
trying to touch it would have been
better yo you're you're yo you're famous
now y f yo I'm going make sure the
[__] are in the thumbnail too
stupid